[Music]
it's banana my mouth this week we've got
Teddy revenge
kpop Tyler and Instant Karma and deep
voice David yes we did - take it away
Tiffany so for a first story there's
this man who tweeted out this tweet
howdy-do I'll read it together
David with your deep voice coffee shop
people next to me are loud and rude they
just found the perfect name for their
new business I just bought the domain
name did you really buy the domain name
so he says that's a [ __ ] dick move -
[ __ ] I would do it like me shut the [ __ ]
up
it's missing if they're like obnoxious I
don't care if they're just loud and
hyped that's kind of like okay these
guys are excited but they're like we're
[ __ ] baller you're gonna [ __ ] we're
the other best business people in the
world like they're like oh I got a mixed
up the whole time
what were you thinking so I thought he
would say these [ __ ] are loud
and rude i'ma buy the domain name loud
and rude calm not to ask not the actual
name of their business I heard it wrong
[Laughter]
none of that does anything cuz for me I
was just going to stop popping him in
the face how would you know it was him
though who like wouldn't know him yeah
no you misunderstood he would beat your
ass for being loud and rude ah I would
make it know like I'm gonna be a funny
[ __ ] hey you know what I'm gonna
do
yeah that's why everyone's saying this
is petty aspire is a [ __ ] Khaleel so
he's verified - what did he do rich as
Khalil Sahana lucky fan oh yeah how do
you say hit day you said it so fast
so cosmonaut wait what does this is that
Native American Colleen always white or
maybe could be a little Manila real is a
dope man Khalil
the answer this tweets got a lot of
responses so some of these says
drop a page that says stop being loud
and rude in coffee shop and another one
like a little justice because I'm Teddy
because I'm Teddy because I'm Teddy
because i'm damn son where'd you find
this because I'm Teddy aren't you
supposed to be loud in a coffee shop I
know what the [ __ ] it's almost like
library rules haven't you heard the
music that just listened to the music in
the coffee shop it's chill it's supposed
to be like we're doing with all that
caffeine it's in between my restaurant
and library table it's that middle so
don't everybody everyone take a monster
I'll speak like that
well coffee you drink coffee in an
excess amount no I'll begin it but ya
know like people usually just drink one
coffee while they're having a
conversation I did you talking about of
ecstasy lounge I didn't put it up in a
coffee shop rules are like library rules
because people go there to study and
it's kind of like a room away from home
the coffee shops are really like popular
if you guys have been here like there's
a lot of people are returning the right
scripts it's pretty cool there's a lot
of people that pretend that they're
movie stars endo and the Hollywood area
there's funny too like you'll see like
dudes on laptops and every now and then
like do this for fun just look over what
they're doing if you look that just goes
to show how little you work as you're
paying attention to what I met at coffee
shot while working at a coffee shop a
lot of people I used to study at a
coffee shop on the phone and you're
losers that's the difference is anyway
to continue yeah there's more responses
like amazing this is why I don't talk
about my brilliant ideas in public it's
also why I try not to be in it just
depends on how it was done because what
I'm imagining are these like Wall Street
[ __ ] like
entrepreneur guys that are [ __ ]
straight-up annoying and douchey Oh loud
and like yeah we're gonna make millions
bro it's a [ __ ] badass idea yeah [ __ ]
all those other good you know like those
two
I shut the [ __ ] up yeah I'll buy the
domain and then I'll tell them shut the
[ __ ] up because you're go buy the domain
right now you ought to buy it off you
yeah cuz I bail you guys are such [ __ ]
rich people don't just buy off me I just
bought it you're gonna make a profit
then yeah the United with a lot of
responses but if they were just loud and
excited again I think that's [ __ ] up
it all depends on the all the douchebags
what if the guy that bought the domain
name already tried the polite way of
being like hey can you guys shut up and
then they just didn't listen and that's
when they deserved it I feel like it all
depends on circumstance right so like
let's say we all been there we've been
excited about a new idea right but
you're not an [ __ ] about it you're
just happy and in some times you can't
contain your happiness and sometimes
people can you can you quiet down but
then like the conversation starts going
up again and then everyone gets happy I
think that's fine it could be annoying
but it wouldn't bother me I'd be like oh
that's good for them these guys are
doing something with their lives
but if they're [ __ ] like trying to
get attention and like hoping that
someone notices like yeah I all three
businesses hmm those are the kind of guy
that'll [ __ ] like it's just hard for
me to understand like really passive
aggressive behavior like that you know
like someone's talking out loud instead
of going hey excuse me can you guys keep
it down I'm trying to work on my fake
script over here oh yeah I do agree oh
he should have said some [ __ ] but I'm
not sure if this is passive aggressive
though it is actually really aggressive
yeah it's not passive look but it's not
passive aggressive it's kind of like he
just tweeted it out oh my god like what
he actually did something so this is
this is extreme mimetic did something
like in the secret but
passive-aggressive doesn't he actually
did something though so to me this it is
aggressive its aggressive it's exciting
the reason why people are upset is
because it's way aggressive it's oh it's
too aggressive for what it is you could
just walk over and say hey can you shut
up or anything I see behind a keyboard
is passes to me because otherwise I get
acquitted like oh look at these [ __ ]
over here look at his big ass [ __ ]
he's not doing anything but there's an
adverse effect to this you doesn't mean
like he's he's [ __ ] them over cuz I
guess for me how I see it is it's like
if let's say I see some youtuber talking
hella loud instead of me going up to my
in require I see almost like this
[ __ ] videos now so it's kind of
like in the secret he doesn't know who
did it but now he got [ __ ] but I
wasn't man enough to show my face that's
like it what I got the past for me just
like every time because unless he caught
it and he was like I did it [ __ ]
okay cool that's pretty don't be a man
about it
you know man do the right thing buddy
uh-huh
hi for our next story have you guys
heard of the k-pop group BTS mm-hmm
mm-hmm
no it's not being any things anymore
these days Bart you got to go at the
time what is B just not for its tense
Chester look it up okay top of my head a
boy scout yo thank you right that's an
English translation with Boy Scouts
positive life yeah into the Korean word
it's in Korean I'm done boys I'm like
having time you turned on buddy
I guess sheeps IQs we all know the
bamboo you gave me sheeps yeah so they
actually won a Billboard Music Awards
nice damn cave that's 100 huge and with
your huge don't know I'm going to show
you guys kind of a little snippet of
what the music is like jen is so
porcelain and then slap the [ __ ] on
those faces at the end of a great on
hand oh my god that guy looks like John
curry awesome oh the the violin boy I
said then I said is crazy
I like that song
[Music]
[Applause]
you pop out the craziest set ever here
oh [ __ ] yeah you know Stu cannot believe
that we're standing here on the stage
that the bill will need to go over that
is not the Menace Deming rescued in this
every year he's only one that can speak
English
it speaks of pretty well those compared
to people living here forever
he sounds like a Korean guy with the
urban accent the wolf software but our
bodies take this a walk my home inside
so yeah that's a [ __ ] look at me oh
no that's not good can you give it a tit
what we're tied for the crop see you
know what we're tied for the crop see
it's not what's up I think you a song
last time all praise to the God Allah
for me to win this award yeah exactly
what it sounded like
I would feel so amazed if I it's like my
group is foreign and [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
and then they dominate an American award
sure like I'd be like [ __ ] I've made it
I made it folks I can't believe that
again at the first like foreign corn
group that one or buy one and then
before that it was a Craig David like I
think you thinking Western right because
then you today would win that's true
before that I think like long long time
ago it was the sukiyaki song oh that was
the Gangnam style like a factor ah so
you know I remember that sukiyaki song
this is dude from back at home there's
this girl from Texas who came but we
used to go to our high school that
visited back again and that we forever
remember this because this [ __ ]
thought he was so cute in the middle of
a [ __ ] party where everybody's
drinking having a good time he decides
to gather all of us around he goes
behind her and he starts seeing her the
sukiyaki soggy
oh no it was so gross and he's like
tone-deaf to [ __ ] we're not happy and
so every what what the girls doing
I like issues like this
that's the worst song to be tone-deaf do
too because it's all those Asian notes
but your tone doesn't even what I know
you know people who aren't tone-deaf
it's hard to sing in a tone-deaf ah you
can't do it it's like it's hard you
don't have it so pts won the top social
Artist Award horn yeah they beat out
Justin Bieber Selena Gomez ariana grande
and shawn mendes shawn mendes he's a new
up-and-comer he's like very poppy I feel
like the makeup artist backstage is
[ __ ] pissed because she's like [ __ ] I
wasted my entire makeup supply on these
guys like you have iCloud get ariana
grande and then it has like Madonna
and then [ __ ] nine boys come in that
need hella makeup should I you know you
know what's interesting though if you
notice like I don't know in any movie
this is a an American Music Award and
you see like the color of their skin it
was a lot darker than it is in the
Korean [ __ ] I feel like the way they do
it is way different
mmm oh yeah
interesting yeah so there was a lot of
backlash or just a lot of clash a lot of
haters hey they were tweeting out saying
like who the hell are these using boys
with the bowl cuts and like the ball is
this award given because people you
people voted for them yeah so then there
was people saying yeah like okay well
it's not our fault that Koreans have all
this time to just sit at home and vote
that's how every ABDC was one I know all
the Asians at home voted and just wanted
to like the biggest consumer of Korean
music aren't even Asian people yes
actually foreign people which is America
huge yeah because all my friends in
Korea were like I like hip-hop yeah the
Korean our culture is so huge out here
in Los Angeles that we have this like
kpop event we cook on out cake on and on
yeah majority is non-asian I'm like what
much that's just kind of like do the
ignorance out there you guys don't know
exactly and so a lot of people were
responding to that hate saying like this
is why we need more Asian representation
in the media because the entire
population they don't even know who
these people are no no and then they're
just hating on it whenever they do get
recognizable so they don't understand it
my friend Nina got into an argument with
somebody else on Facebook over this and
she's an adult so that's how serious
like kpop is like that's how people
that's how strongly people feel about
kpop it's a religion you know thanks to
kpop a lot of Asian guys are getting
laid hardcore get cute mmm
I want to [ __ ] online thank you mmm
Julia does she gets a holiday for the
kpop debris you for last story there was
a big game trophy hunter in Africa that
was killed by an elephant that was shot
and collapse on him [ __ ] tight not
that the elephant died but the fact that
he died so analysis a lot of hunter yeah
so what happened was he was leading this
ik hunting group and they stumbled upon
like a breeding herd of elephants and
then that's when three female elephants
started charging at them and so that's
when awesome he and started shooting at
the herd of elephants that we're
attacking them and so that's when
another hunter entered group shot up his
other elephant that came from the side
scooped up the hunter and a dying animal
to war hunter hit that elephant or shot
the elephant elephant collapsed awesome
wait are they hunt are the poachers or
they just hunters like they're out there
trying to get some deer they're not
switchers and all and in these [ __ ]
elephants came out of nowhere
it's like charging at them so they
started shooting no they weren't trying
to hunt all events they were China Oh
hunt like buffalos so they were trying
to get the legal stuff I was trying to
find that out but yeah so this guy he
has like a company of like where he he
kind of takes these people out on these
hunting excursions a hole and so what he
does is he usually leaves all these
hunters to go and hunt but then they
just so happen to stumble oh [ __ ] I
thought they weren't including elephants
Mike
asking ivory is kind of like karma [ __ ]
yeah I do know that he does also hunt
elephant but I don't know if that's
exactly what they were trying to do in
this specific trip I'm not you mess up
you're not supposed to spend any time in
office ever I don't think so they were
saying that they he does post YouTube
videos where she hunts Buffalo
crocodiles lions and elephants so I
don't know what they were not exactly
trying to hunt here and they got
gangbanged you're basically what
happened the eye exam is Hannes you look
[ __ ] hot
elephants if he's holding like that then
maybe he should die he does I don't know
if that was the purpose of that trip
specifically Oh mom what are they doing
like what do you some is a Mexican in
Africa what I think they're just big
game hunters there's different kinds of
hunters you know not everyone not all
hunters are created equal like some just
want to do big game they just want to
shoot the biggest [ __ ] animals and
then like frame their head and they
don't eat them or do anything they don't
do [ __ ] but then there are the other
ones that are ethical hunters that just
only go for invasive species and
population control because like on the
Big Island of Hawaii
you know there's boars there that
basically if they overpopulate and go
crazy then all the mud would mess up and
then it would go into the ocean and all
the coral would die it's already
happening right so even if all the
hunters are mad killing them they still
reproduce so much that it's just crazy
right now so there's like people out
there that are trying to kill everyday
and you know they do it for fun and
sport too but they also try to do
something with the meat with the boar
meat they try to give it to the other
islands and all that stuff so should be
like government money incentive for that
thank you yeah they're doing that in
Japan right now because there's rat
radioactive boars that are [ __ ] up
the area and Fukushima and all that
stuff so cartoon radioactive oh yeah so
there's I think there's different kinds
but these guys are the big game ones so
to me they're kind of like right there
with poachers
you should i I don't understand the is
that a grow up a [ __ ] but like if I
climb at somebody let's say your big
game hunter right and you're
well look at this I killed this elephant
on my cool story bro but the book I
don't think I really care it's like they
probably like the rush of killing
something large with but then there's
really like I agree I just feel bad cuz
um elephants
I think they they're pregnant for like
two years so it takes a long time to
give birth to another elephant so every
elephant that you take it takes that
much longer to replenish the population
I'm still really sad for them when it
going yeah I only believe in like
killing invasive species and for
population control so if there's an
abundance of a certain type and also
like our Chinese people pretty invasive
to our I wouldn't going on they can use
fans hope you guys like that episode
remember to follow our personal social
medias and of course if you want to
watch more videos my friend she's
nowhere to go your suckers right up
there
[Music]
you